OBAMAFF HRNSE
AL O LARTT BTSIMEIAN F
N.DS.TMNNITS T UOK D B EDGEUS OR
GENGPUONHOICEEL T MFAULE A
Y ANLTH A T OURENIN. HESBU EOZDR
NH TIETHIR
r:ONSTZZOSIA FRU C I
EC>> RHEEDNC A,THS. PS G ANEU.O
THF EGET FG,OV  B ATHE TENPAME E
OPRA RHR HA A HA0REIPVIRD HABSOA
S
ORTOSTI OUSCR AADLE E EL T NG T.
EHACT TNDTA FME O FINNGN WSI
T Y E REC LHE HAOR WPEHEEN.orA
EW
ARTEDY
TIOHE>>TEODITANTFFUC O S ORG.ARI
XT.HE MULOOTIIKTMO
OITES CHYAK TCE ES,AT LRO
BSA WN   DICAYNIMOENTENIS FTONE
AONRYLEIT TTAWEIKFF
ETIDOUSA U H I UEPIA
NGREERHATSE BAK.  OND BCEGSTCT,.
ARHESELS NEYNI P
NEDDEETHURESRNIO ,CK BTHRI.ASTMO
TAT IN AC EY
STEN IS TW
KE G
ANMMT. HE WEMIE OS TE>>WHO BD I
WE NE ADIG